crítico del partido democrático
unionista pongan renunció en protesta
por el protocolo de irlanda del norte
que fue firmado entre la unión europea y
el reino unido durante las negociaciones
del break sheet sin embargo este
protocolo sigue siendo la manzana de la
discordia en esta era post break sheet
el consejero de agricultura norirlandés
suspendió de manera unilateral las
inspecciones sanitarias aduaneras de
productos ganaderos y agrícolas
provenientes de gran bretaña algo que
está prohibido en el acuerdo al break
city firmado entre el reino unido y la
unión europea sin embargo estas
inspecciones aduaneras han causado
escasez de productos en irlanda del
norte y nuevas tensiones
la región el tema no es solamente
comercial sino también de tipo político
ya que los unionistas que son leales a
la corona británica están tratando de
fijar su postura de cara a las próximas
elecciones en la provincia de irlanda
del norte
el protocolo de irlanda sigue siendo un
dolor de cabeza en esta era post break
shit